bienvenidos a este programa especial la
serie france24 enfocado en los retos que
enfrentará el presidente entrante de
eeuu joe biden
yo soy andrés meza muñoz la emergencia
provocada por el joven 19 también trajo
consigo devastadoras consecuencias
económicas para el mundo apropiarse de
la lucha contra esta crisis en estados
unidos ha sido una promesa de campaña de
biden en nuestro último capítulo echamos
un vistazo a la realidad que enfrenta el
país los pequeños negocios han sido los
más afectados por la falta de recursos
para aguantar la crisis nuestro
corresponsal en washington cristóbal
vázquez conoció a un empresario que se
vio obligado a cerrar varios de sus
negocios debido a las restricciones de
bioseguridad y los que mantiene abiertos
se sostienen gracias a la ayuda del
gobierno que ya se les acabó histórico
que más quieren marc cuando empezó el
commit en marzo tenía seis negocios
abiertos operando y en buen estado
trayendo tres de esos negocios eran
estudios de yoga este es uno de ellos
dupont circle yoga y tres tiendas de
café y café
hoy elías solo tiene abiertas tres
tiendas de café y es que cerca de
110.000 establecimientos han cerrado en
eeuu equivalentes al 17% de los
restaurantes del país
de bebés no la realidad es que no hay un
caso para que los negocios sigan
abiertos la única razón por la que
estamos abiertos es para proteger a
nuestros trabajadores y generar algo de
ingresos
aunque se ha recuperado en los últimos
meses la cifra de desempleo en eeuu es
de cerca de 10 7 millones de personas
casi el doble que antes de la pandemia
sin ayuda federal adicional
en la segunda ronda de préstamos a
pequeños negocios que viene pronto ojalá
muy pronto
habrá muchos negocios como los nuestros
que no llegarán a la primavera por el
plan de rescate del presidente electo
incluye 19 billones de dólares para
pequeños negocios y para hacer frente a
la pandemia
de casi 400.000 pequeños negocios han
cerrado permanentemente sus puertas
y no es difícil ver que estamos en la
mitad de una crisis económica que sólo
ocurre en una de tantas generaciones
crisis a veces creo que con esta nueva
administración lo que todos esperamos es
simplemente cuatro años muy aburridos y
el aburrimiento la rutina y dejar que la
gente regrese a lo normal es bueno para
los negocios predictibilidad es bueno
para los negocios y es que texas el plan
de estímulo económico que propone joe
biden de 19 billones de dólares para
pequeños negocios y el kobe incluye
pagos directos de 1400 dólares a todos
los estadounidenses que ganen menos de
75 mil dólares al año un salario mínimo
federal de 15 dólares por hora y
beneficios de desempleo más generosos y
350 mil
para los gobiernos estatales y locales
para cubrir los déficit presupuestarios
otra propuesta para la recuperación
económica incluyen la creación de más de
18,6 millones de empleos en los primeros
cuatro años de gobierno la inversión de
2 billones de dólares en un plan de
energía e infraestructura llamado build
back better recovery plan y una
transición a economía verde que no emita
gases de efecto invernadero al 2050 juan
carlos echeverry ex ministro de hacienda
de colombia ex presidente de ecopetrol y
ex director por colombia ante el banco
interamericano de desarrollo desde
washington nos contó cuáles son los
principales retos que enfrentará la
administración de joe biden en los
próximos cuatro años una crisis es por
definición debe partir sufrimiento
social y el sufrimiento social en esta
crisis ha sido inmenso y ha estado
distribuido de manera muy inequitativo
hay muchas regiones que ya habían
perdido en puestos de trabajo ya han
perdido empresas y ahora perdieron pues
mucho mucha fuente de ingresos
y regiones más golpeadas que otras
entonces yo creo que el primer siempre
siempre el primer problema es cómo
mitigar el sufrimiento social el segundo
punto es volver a crecer y aquí pues ahí
se ha dicho que si la economía iba a
escribir una web
perfecta y ahí la verdad es que el año
2020 escribió de salud con este episodio
concluye la serie de france 24 sobre los
retos de joe biden como presidente de
eeuu los invitamos a que no se pierdan
nuestro cubrimiento especial sobre la
toma de posesión del líder demócrata
este 20 de enero a las 11 horas bogotá
quito lima quédense con nosotros
[Música]